on this wednesday night the risks of
reopening schools
mounting questions from millions of
parents and kids
masking will probably be more useful
with older children
and the new guidelines that give new
meaning to distance learning
plus quebec's new outbreaks as more
rules there are about to be relaxed
defending the way they do business we
are
very very focused on the customer four
tech titans testified before u.s
lawmakers
about competition and predatory
practices
and a dog's nose nose
harnessing the power of pooches to
detect kobit 19.
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
with september fast approaching there's
no doubt the back to school experience
will be complex and confusing this year
what school will look like whether kids
are fully back in class will depend on
where you live
and the amount of community transmission
of covid19
there is some updated guidance on how
schools can reopen
safely doctors from toronto sick kids
hospital in other ontario pediatric
hospitals recommend
smaller class sizes more teachers
cleaning staff and hygiene facilities
and
outdoor education where possible it is a
tricky balance the risk of infection
versus the impact on kids
development education and mental health
by keeping them at home
as eric sorenson reports it's something
governments across this country
are struggling with it's one of the most
contentious debates
how to send kids back to school during a
pandemic
in ontario some parents protested at
mpp's offices
demanding more funding to make schools
safe and class sizes smaller
i'm very interested in making sure my
kids for their mental and physical
well-being get back in school
but only in a very safe way a legend
survey finds parents of children remain
worried
59 percent are prepared to send their
kids back to school
but 23 percent don't know and 18 plan to
keep them home in september
specialists from sick kids and other
ontario hospitals
are pushing to reopen schools as fully
as possible
with precautions because there are
health and economic consequences
from kids not going to school the major
goal of reopening schools
has to be maximizing child
and youth health in returning to school
the health care group is now
recommending for elementary students
one meter distancing it's almost as
effective as two they say
and for high schoolers to wear
non-medical masks
in school when possible because they do
more good than harm
masking will probably be more useful
with older children
especially if social distancing cannot
be maintained
now british columbia has released plans
to open schools in september
full-time high school students will be
limited to cohorts of 120
elementary and middle school children to
learning groups of 60.
and that seems like a lot that's not all
in the same classroom
but it will be segregating by
by grades so that there's less mingling
in the school environment
bc is the latest to plan for students to
return full time
it joins alberta saskatchewan quebec
atlanta canada and the territories
where the aim is full time in school for
elementary and high school students
with some exceptions manitoba and
ontario are still considering
full-time or online or a hybrid
combination
but with more details expected this week
meantime alberta has just seen a spike
in kovitt 19 cases
and the potential for more outbreaks
worries some educators
about opening all the schools all at
once
i don't think it's helpful to have
schools closed 100
at the end of august and then the next
day in september to be
opening up 100 i think it's really
important that we do a phased approach
it seems a massive epidemiological
experiment is set to begin about one
month from now
when more than five million canadian
youngsters are scheduled to return to
school
eric sorensen global news toronto
the city of toronto which reported just
13 new cases today
and the peel region are moving to stage
three of ontario's reopening plan on
friday
that means playgrounds community centers
and libraries will reopen as will indoor
dining at bars and restaurants
strict public health restrictions remain
in place though when masks are mandatory
indoors unless you're eating drinking or
exercising
toronto's mayor says personal
responsibility is key
to making this work we just have to keep
doing the right thing as we've been
doing
uncomfortable sometimes inconvenient or
sometimes as complicated
as that may be keep wearing a mask or
face covering as often as you possibly
can
in quebec there have been setbacks that
have led to some restrictions being
reimposed
a particular concern is a cluster of
cases at a day camp on montreal's south
shore
some public pools and liquor store
outlets have also closed after outbreaks
as mike armstrong reports quebec is
still pushing ahead with an overall plan
to ease restrictions public health
officials ordered this day camp
closed a week ago when it had just a
handful of positive covid 19 cases
in the days since between staff and
children it's
jumped all the way to twenty seven
mariteres dupree lives next door
kids they touch each other it might try
to transfer from one to the other
and then to their parents and other kids
at home
all children and staff at the facility
have been told to quarantine at home
the public health department is ramping
up tracing and testing
but there have now been outbreaks at
about 15 quebec
day camps most of them small
the association of day camps says it
isn't surprised there have been coveted
19 cases that was expected and
considering about a thousand camps have
been open for close to two months
it says 15 outbreaks isn't terrible that
said the setbacks are starting to pile
up
pools in one borough of montreal are
shut down this week after three positive
tests
it turns out about 80 percent of the
borough's lifeguards went to a party
together
quebec also announced wednesday it's
closing three provincial liquor stores
north of montreal
after eight employees tested positive
and in sherbert quebec beaches and pools
have been closed
and as of wednesday five members of a
ball hockey team tested positive
the deputy premier has been pointing
fingers at part of the problem
we need young people so we are asking
them work with us
help us help you and respect the rules
right now quebec limits public
gatherings at 50 people but that's
supposed to go up to 250 monday
that appears to be going ahead despite
the setbacks
people have to understand that nothing's
going to be risk-free moving forward we
have to figure out how to live
with this problem until we find
effective therapeutics and vaccines and
and you know there are no guarantees in
that court either
the plan is to continue with precautions
and vigilance
and as long as fires are being put out
as quickly as they can be found
this appears to be the new reality
mike armstrong global news boucherville
quebec
there's been another big jump in
infections in saskatchewan
the province says 50 more people have
tested positive
44 of them are from a single hutterite
colony
according to premier scott moe
hutterites now account for 76 percent of
saskatchewan's 322 active cases
and today he issued a direct message to
those communities
every single one of us in this province
has been asked to
and the vast majority have changed how
we are living each and every day
you all need to as well if you don't
many will get sick in your community
some will get very sick some will die
in the coming days moe says officials
will be visiting every hutterite colony
in saskatchewan
to ensure public health orders are being
obeyed
the situation is still getting worse in
many parts of the united states
more than 150 000 americans have now
died from covid19
and there's no slowdown in sight the
white house coronavirus task force now
classifies 21 states as being in the
so-called
red zone that means they have high
levels of infection
and positive tests as jackson proskow
reports there's still no national plan
to try to bring the virus
under control the uncontrolled spread of
covid19 is delivering deadly
consequences across the u.s
icu's they're awful we are finding ways
to macgyver
things running out of supplies
for the second day in a row florida
recorded a record number of deaths
more than 200 california shattered its
one day record for fatalities
texas reported more than 8 thousand new
cases
more and more states are on the verge of
becoming hot spots
tipping into territory that will bring
the certainty of more death
we do still need a national strategy and
many of us
in the public health and and health
professional sphere have been asking for
it
but candidly six months into this in the
united states i'm not expecting anything
and that's
unfortunate as the virus spreads the
bitter partisan divide over the pandemic
grows worse in washington republican
congressman louie gohmert
tested positive for kobit 19 less than
24 hours after attending a hearing with
the u.s attorney general
gohmert has often refused to wear a mask
and seem to blame face coverings for his
diagnosis
when i have a mask on i'm moving it to
make it comfortable
and i can't help but wonder if that
you know put some germs in the mask
the science on masks testing and
prevention remains clear
that has not been enough to change the
course of decision making in the u.s
president donald trump has returned to
pushing conspiracy theories about the
virus
promoting the word of a doctor who has
claimed there's a cure for covid19
and who believes alien dna is used in
medical treatments
i was very impressed by her know nothing
about her i had never seen her before
but certainly you could put her up and
let her have a voice without a change in
the trajectory of the pandemic the
warnings about where it's all headed are
increasingly grim
the american association of medical
colleges warns that the death toll
is likely to reach the multiple hundreds
of thousands
donna jackson in washington thanks
the governor of oregon says after
discussions with vice president mike
pence the white house has agreed to
withdraw federal agents from portland
she says they'll begin leaving the city
tomorrow the governor says the federal
agents dressed in camouflage and with no
id
have acted as an occupying force and
brought violence president trump sent
them to the city to protect a federal
courthouse
since the death of george floyd there
have been likely nightly protests in
downtown portland and federal agents
have been heavily criticized for their
tactics
though the governor says they're now
leaving president trump said today the
remaining agents will not leave until
local authorities have as he says
secured
the city in this country tomorrow prime
minister justin trudeau and his top aide
will testify before the house of commons
finance committee
the ethics commissioner is also
investigating the prime minister and
finance minister bill morneau for
possible violations of conflict of
interest rules
they've admitted they did not recuse
themselves from cabinet discussions
about a
multi-million dollar student grant
program even though they both had
personal connections to the we charity
michael couture will be among those
watching mike the opposition is going to
pounce on the prime minister
what can we expect donna a senior
government source tells global news the
prime minister's biggest regret
is his family has been dragged into this
we're also being told trudeau will again
apologize for not recusing himself from
the cabinet decision
to give we charity the nearly billion
dollar contract
that source also says 100 of the story
is already public and justin trudeau
is appearing so the focus can get back
to helping youth
in the country but opposition mps are
more focused on trudeau
he should come tomorrow and tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
for once and if opposition mps think
trudeau hasn't done that
conservative pierre polyev says they'll
drag the prime minister
back before the committee and do it all
over again
following testimony by the kilberger
brothers the co-founders of the we
charity
conservatives have new questions about
the auxiliary expenses
paid out by the charity to trudeau's
family members
for a number of appearances within weeks
of
one of these trips the government
engages
the we organization to deliver a program
worth half
a billion dollars why did he choose to
help his close friends
instead of helping students who are in
need of some supports
as much as the prime minister hopes his
appearance will turn the focus back
to the pandemic response it won't turn
down the heat on trudeau
he still has to answer questions from
the ethics commissioner
who is investigating his role in the
government's decision
to choose we charity donna
okay mike locator thanks four of the
world's biggest bosses
facing accusations coming up the tech
giants hold
too much power plus an update on the
case of the stolen teddy bear
in vancouver
[Music]
this is the fiery aftermath of a freight
train derailment in arizona
it caused a four kilometer bridge to
partially collapse
the train was carrying wood and oil when
it jumped the tracks and burst into
flames this morning
no crew members were hurt four of the
world's wealthiest and most influential
men faced a reckoning in washington
today
they had the four big tech companies
that dominate our lives
but i recognize that there are concerns
about the size and power of tech
companies
our services are about connection and
our business model is advertising and
we face intense competition in both
facebook's mark zuckerberg and the men
who run amazon apple and google were
grilled virtually by a congressional
subcommittee together they're worth
about five trillion dollars and there
are lots of questions about their
business practices and influence
their companies are under an anti-trust
microscope looking at the monopolies
they've created
their competition tactics and how they
utilize user data
because these companies are so central
to our modern life
their business practices and decisions
have an outsized effect on our economy
and our democracy any single action by
one of these companies can affect
hundreds of millions of us
in profound and lasting ways
it was the first time amazon's jeff
bezos faced congress he's the world's
wealthiest man and he was asked about
how amazon undercuts competitors
and its own third-party vendors with
predatory practices
in 2013 it was reported that you
instructed amazon employees to approach
discussions with certain business
partners and i quote
the way a cheetah would pursue a sickly
gazelle
is the gazelle project still in place
and does amazon pursue
similar predatory campaigns in other
parts of its business
i i i cannot comment on that because i
don't remember it
multiple times the ceos evaded questions
claiming not to know specifics about the
documents or the interactions they were
asked about
critics say they damaged the economy by
killing off smaller businesses and
strangling competition and that
government regulation is required
a report on the investigation is due to
be released in the fall
still ahead a sinkhole in china swallows
two people
well how's this for being in the wrong
place at the wrong time two pedestrians
in china were swallowed up by a huge
sinkhole
when the sidewalk suddenly collapsed
both survived they have minor injuries
authorities believe recent torrential
rains caused the sidewalk to give way
there's growing concern hong kong may be
on the verge of a new outbreak of
covid19
hong kong is struggling with a surge in
new cases nearly all of them are the
result of community transmission
leader kerry lam warns it may cause
hospitals
to collapse strict new measures are put
in place
to help stop the spread of the virus and
lamb is urging the public to follow the
rules gatherings are now limited
to two people restaurants are no longer
allowed to offer dine-in services and
residents must wear a mask when they
leave home
hong kong which had a relatively low
number of cases
is now regularly reporting over 100 new
infections
per day the hajj has begun in saudi
arabia
and it looks very different this year
strict limits have been put on the
number of pilgrims allowed into the holy
city of mecca
only 10 000 worshipers are permitted and
they must wear masks
move in groups of no more than 20 and
maintain physical distance
the hajj normally attracts up to 2
million muslims from around the world
saudi arabia has reported more than 272
000 cases of covet 19.
recruiting rovers next training dogs to
lead the pandemic
by the nose
you're watching global national
no matter where you are apart the blue
will always be with you forever
those are the words mara soriano wanted
to hear again her bear with a recording
of her mother's voice was stolen last
week in vancouver while
she was moving and now it's been
returned her mother marilyn passed away
from cancer last year so the bear was
very precious
and yesterday a man returned it to her
safe and sound
i feel amazing i just feel just so happy
to have her back and not only that it
just
is incredible to feel the love and
kindness and compassion from everyone
who was
involved with the story and i'm just so
i'm speechless
news of the theft spread on social media
thousands retweeted it and vancouver
born actor ryan reynolds offered a five
thousand dollar reward for the bear
mara says that money has been sent to
the person who returned the bear and
she's extended
an invitation to reynolds he's invited
to her wedding
where the bear might be the ring bearer
some other beloved animals are proving
to be a valuable tool in the fight
against covid19
a new study suggests that dogs are able
to sniff out the new coronavirus with
remarkable accuracy
and very little training jeff semple
went to see a man
about a dog
canine's keen sense of smell has helped
to sniff out
illegal drugs explosives even missing
people
and now this pack is also lending a paw
in the fight
against an invisible threat when the
pandemic was
coming to germany we were thinking oh
could we actually help
with helping with dogs this german
researcher and his team
trained eight military dogs to smell
saliva from people
with covid19 they tested more than a
thousand samples both healthy and
infected
and the pups picked correctly 94
of the time after just one week of
training
we were also really amazed how fast
these dogs learn
the scent receptors in this schnoz are
up to ten thousand times better than
ours
the four-legged friends have previously
been trained to detect bacteria
and a dozen human diseases including
malaria and diabetes
the thing what dogs don't smell this the
virus right
they smell what the virus does to our
body let's go
glenn ferguson's dogs have conducted
cancer screening for nearly 40
000 firefighters in canada and the
united states
by smelling their breath samples i think
you know as far as the utility for dogs
with covid
you know testing for cobia 19 is that it
can be done quickly
current covid19 tests require a throat
or nasal swab
and can sometimes take several days to
produce a result
these dogs sniffed out the virus in
seconds
so to have a dog in front of a school or
in an airport or a bus or a train
station certainly makes a lot of sense
chile is planning to do
just that training its police dogs to
sniff for covid19
in busy public spaces though some like
this veterinary professor
worry they're putting the pups at risk
and there's only a few cases but the
evidence is strong enough to say that
pets are infectable and cats likely more
so than
dogs and it's unclear whether dogs could
pick up the scent in a passerby or
someone with mild symptoms
the german study used samples from
covid19 patients who'd been hospitalized
but the pooch potential begs further
study
this small group alone could screen more
than four thousand people
in a single day jeff semple global news
toronto
that's global national for this
wednesday i'm donna freeze and we leave
you tonight with the new two dollar coin
or pictures of it anyway
and pays tribute to the late hide artist
bill reid
the mint rolled out this tuning on what
would have been his 100th birthday it
features a grizzly
bear a central figure and reads
groundbreaking work
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye